the right to return bill is officially
law in nevada as of yesterday it
essentially guarantees certain
hospitality workers
who lost their jobs during the shutdown
that they'll be rehired but
some workers still feel left behind orco
mana joins us live on the strip
to explain why orco
well brian as resorts here ramp up
normal operations more and more people
in the hospitality industry are getting
back to work workers tell us that they
are waiting for that
and some casino companies tell us that
that's not exactly the best way to go
about it
i wanted my job for 36 years mario
sandoval worked as a food server at
binions then he was laid off in march
2020 during the covet 19 shutdown
financially
it was devastating emotionally
i can tell you on the third month i went
through a depression
but he says there's now a light at the
end of the tunnel he got notified he'll
be back to work in the next month
that felt really good the right to
return bill guarantees certain workers
their former positions or similar ones
once those jobs become available
they must be tourism-related employees
who were let go due to the pandemic and
worked for at least six months of the
year
preceding march 12 2020. priority is
given to those with seniority and they
have 24 hours to accept or decline an
offer
station casino sending this letter to
former full-time staff members
saying because the law's rules about
return order are confusing
they would not be filling jobs they
normally would because those jobs are
not available
that includes at buffets we spoke to a
former employee at green valley ranch's
buffet
i only want to work you know i want all
all i lost in this time i want to get it
back
referencing other major resorts the
culinary union tells us in part quote
they are bringing workers back at the
same level of seniority pay and benefits
it would be a shame if the non-union
companies don't follow the standard set
by the largest gaming employers in
nevada
station casino is pushing back saying
they've hired more than 1500 employees
and quote
everyone has received the same or better
pay with great station casinos benefits
workers standing united we have the
right to return to work
again we want to stress that stations
casinos
is hiring people back just they just
don't have all the positions
available that they did before the
pandemic the new law took effect on july
1st
and will expire at the end of august
2022
reporting live on the las vegas strip
tonight orgomana 8 news now